[Musique]
et nos invités françois chauve ancier
général de brigade expert en
géostratégie et barmaids journalistes
maliens messieurs bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
françois chauds vend si des opérations
servent à la barre kahn huit ans
d'engagement donc et plus de 50 soldats
français tués la guerre menée par paris
au sahel
elle est perdue bon et puis quand on
découvre un portage on a quand même
l'impression qu'on se trouve un petit
peu de sujets je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une guerre qu'on peut
qualifier de contre-insurrectionnelle
face à des gens partie comment
déterminer qui sont peu nombreux et
qu'ils ont subi de très lourdes pertes
depuis des années nous sommes là pour
stabiliser la région en attendant
justement comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
souligné que finalement le politique
reprenne la main c'est ce que nous
attendons alors non je ne crois pas que
nous soyons dans une guerre perdue nous
sommes une guerre l'on à ce type de
guerre c'est forcément long et il faut
faire avec et acceptées quant aux au
nombre de tués 50 tués
je me permettrais de dire on aura nos
soldats mais 50 tués en huit ans cela
fait peu de soldats tués chaque année
c'est toujours trop mais quand on fait
la guerre il est normal de perdre des
hommes babar ahmad emmanuel macron a
souvent ces derniers temps pointé un
problème de sentiments anti français au
sahel et qu'il fallait un soutien local
des populations justement quel est le
sentiment sur place vis-à-vis de l'armée
française je pense que comme les général
l'a vu en fait la vision africaine
sahélienne n'est pas la même barque
français car le général dit que c'est
une guerre longue c'est une guerre a
reculé sahélien c'est une guerre qui
doit être court je vous rappelle que au
mali pas régulièrement la crise a
commencé depuis 2012 on est en 2020 donc
ça fait 9 ans neva citron pour cette
population déjà fragile l'opération
marque en tant que tel on a vu l'année
passée des manifestations contre la
présence française contre cette
opération française tout simplement
parce que certains jugent qu'elle est
inefficace et pour cause
elle est là les français sont là avec
des moyens sophistiqués pourtant la
crise ne fait que grandir
n'est ce pas c'est un moment donné et
puis plus les années passent la présence
française est là mais la décembre de
santé du mali emma est maintenant
tellement ça tend plus vers le sud du
pays comme on a vu il y à il ya trois
cadres a été présente dans le sud du
pays et donc c'est tout ça qui fatiguent
cette population qui pense que la guerre
a trop duré
et quand les génériques justement cette
position là c'est une guerre longue
justement je vous propose de voir
messieurs un sondage
ancien il date de 2013 mais sondages
mais l'est également avec ce qui se
passe maintenant à regarder les français
veulent que la france intervienne en
janvier 2021 à 51%
mais il était pourtant favorable à 75 %
en 2013 comment expliquer cette lente et
progressive érosion françois chavance y
est du côté de la france
je crois qu on a toujours le même
phénomène dans tous les conflits que
nous menons plus une guerre est longue
plus le peuple
la malienne dont on vient de parler on a
assez et le peuple français aussi
simplement parce que les gars longue ne
représente pas grand chose aujourd'hui
on a l'impression de perdre son temps
que ça coûte de l'argent
on ne sait pas toujours où on va malgré
des directions politiques très clair
donc je crois que c'est une usure
normale de tout conflit aujourd'hui
surtout dans les démocraties où surtout
quand on fait beaucoup de médiatisation
autour d'un ou deux soldats tués avec
des cérémonies ça sensibilise les gens
et puis je dirais que c'est une on
n'aime pas la mort on n'aime pas la mort
on n'aime pas la guerre donc c'est
normal qu'au bout de huit ans il ya une
usure de du soutien populaire
mais c'est au rôle des politiques
d'expliquer des choses et puis aussi
d'avoir la détermination d'aller
jusqu'au bout du conflit
même si le peuple en a assez on vient
d'évoquer le peuple malien oui on a sans
doute assez le problème c'est que déjà
le peuple malien devrait commencer à
être des solutions politiques
intérieures qui éviterait de barkan
s'installe et marc année là que
simplement parce qu'il n'ya pas de
solution locale et qu'il faut bien faire
quelque chose à barmaid la france est
une puissance internationale membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu
l'interventionnisme français est une
tradition un pour diverses raisons
au sahel l'une des explications c'est
pas la seule évidemment mais il y à la
lutte contre l'islamisme et contre le
djihadisme pour en limiter notamment
leur venue en europe regardez cette
citation celle de thierry mariani
eurodéputés rassemblement national je
cite on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir
une sorte d' afghanistan bis qui
deviendrait un repaire de terroristes
dans cette partie de l'afrique on serait
immédiatement impacté en termes
d'immigration parce que ça entraînerait
une déstabilisation de la région
il faudra progressivement se retirer en
espérant que les armées africaines
prendront le relais fin de citation
comment lutter contre les groupes
djihadistes sur place sont les moyens de
la france le mali pour les pays dits
sérielle de façon générale la question
moi je pense que la question c'est celle
efficacité de cette opération barkan qui
est en cause aujourd'hui et qui fait
qu'elle est elle est à la fois elle est
à la fois faible au niveau des centres
d'un sondage et au sahel et en france
pour à titre d'exemple seulement je vous
rappelle qu'en 2013 quand l'opération
quand l'opération servat n'a été lancée
et c'était 5000 soldats pour le
territoire malien qui était un million
de kilomètres carrés aujourd'hui on a le
même chiffre pour pour cinq pays du
sahel et donc et le personnel n'est pas
efficace tout simplement
et la preuve est qu est bon bien sûr
qu'il ya des gars il ya des actions qui
élimine n'est ce pas de membres de
groupes d'al qaïda ou de l'état
islamique au sahel
mais c'est pas efficace et c'est là
qu'il faut revoir comment est ce que ray
cadrer cette opération pour qu'elle
devienne efficace et aussi en même temps
de voir comment est-ce que les soldats
nationaux à que ce soit au mali ou au
burkina faso ou au niger puisse monter
en puissance et relever les défis et
c'est ce que la population ne voit pas
on ne voit pas comment est-ce que c'est
la même puce
prendre le relais je vous ai je vous
rappelle que la force conjointe du geste
car elle n'est toujours pas opérationnel
comme cela était si le papier mais comme
cela a été vendu aux populations
sahéliennes et pourquoi cette force ce
n'est toujours pas opérationnel et
pourquoi encore les actions continuent
je veux la fin dit que la paix du
cinquantenaire c'est dommage c'était
grave pour nous c'est de savoir ça mais
le soldat israélien ils sont combien qui
sont mois les des centaines et des
centaines et des centaines et c'est des
milliers de milieu des bulles et des
familles qui sont victimes alors un
moment donné déjà il se pose la question
est ce que cette guerre où est ce qu'on
va aller est ce qu'on va continuer
éternellement et les premières victimes
je vous rappelle que ce sont les séries
donc voilà un peu la situation
aujourd'hui qui fait que l'opération
elle n'est pas efficace il faut le
recadrer
mais la radio comme moi et je pense que
c'est là c'est là la retient de rire en
soit françois souvent si ça chante si la
france peut-être se désengage aussi
c'est peut-être pour mettre en avant les
responsabilités des alliés et peut-être
aussi une question pécuniaire vous
parlez également d'argent tout alors oui
tout à fait bon d'abord la notion
d'efficacité dans des guerres de
contre-insurrection on prend discuter
des heures pour l'instant en gros qu'un
sens jihadistes ont été éliminés
physiquement on les a contrôlés dans un
centre de zones bien précises
les groupes islamistes ne font pas ce
qu'ils veulent sur le terrain ce n'est
pas parce que parfois il ya
effectivement des actions réussies de
leur part que ça prouve qu'ils tiennent
le terrain et on combien d'hommes face à
nous un face à nous on a quelques
milliers de djihadistes sur
effectivement un territoire immense à
laquelle on répond avec des effectifs
barkan n'est pas la seule concernée
barkan ses 5000 hommes
la minus masse et 15000 les armes et on
parle peu de l'europe
il ya également les états unis on sait
qui on sait qu'il doit y avoir un
nouveau chef de la diplomatie américaine
qui qui doit adresser un message vidéo
lors de ce sommet aujourd'hui et demain
à n'djamena anthony blinken
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre justement
de l'europe avec la force d'un coup bas
ou encore des états unis je crois qu'il
faut être réaliste
l'europe ne se sent pas concerné par ce
qui se passe au sahel
ce n'est pas nouveau la france attend
cette internationale l
internationalisation du conflit dans la
mesure où on considère que ce que nous
faisons au mali défend aussi l'europe
par action à direct comme l'a dit la
ministre
nous ne voulons pas que ça devienne une
base d'un djida is éventuelles ensuite
les américains mais les américains nous
est déjà des américains nous aide
logistique mans en renseignement sans
doute qu'ils devraient faire plus je ne
suis pas certain qu'il n'ya pas très
longtemps sa date de quelques jours
le pentagone a laissé sous-entendre un
retrait supplémentaire des forces
américaines présentes présente sur place
alors je ne connais pas l'état des
forces américaines sur place mais je
pense pas qu'elle soit très nombreuses
elles ont pas de force
il n'y a pas de forces américaines
déployées d'une manière organisée
il peut peut-être avoir des bases de
renseignement oui effectivement mais je
crois que le combat aujourd'hui se fait
quand même sur le terrain avec des
soldats et la question que vous avez
posé sur la participation européenne
elle est là et c'est un peu d'ailleurs à
la question qui est posée par monsieur
le journaliste excusez moi j'ai pas
recruter le maintenant c'est vrai qui
fait la guerre sur le terrain et la
première chose qu'on devrait obtenir
sait déjà que les armées locales se
battre correctement et c'est ce que fait
la france
allez on a formé plus de 6000 bien sûr
pas toujours avec efficacité dans la
mesure où sur le terrain ces armes et où
ces unités ne sont pas très efficaces il
faut les aider à être plus efficaces et
c'est l'objectif de talent de ceux de ce
sommet il faut que les locaux prennent
en charge leur sécurité et nous
reconnaissions que c'est pas notre rôle
d'être là en permanence pour assurer
cette sécurité militaire qui doit
assurer par les armées locales et là je
suis bien d'accord en messieurs luis
ayant lieutenant de vaisseau et officier
des forces spéciales a écrit le livre
chefs de guerre aux éditions mareuil il
y raconte les missions ultra dangereuse
pour traquer les djihadistes mais
surtout à regarder cette excitation
il faut arrêter de croire que c'est par
les armes que l'on va les avoir il faut
engager le champ des idées et leur
proposer quelque chose qui à ces
gamins-là les fasse rêver
babara m comment investir le champ des
idées c'est très important
c'est très important d'aller à cette
voie là aussi qui est une piste à
explorer qu'on appelait explorer au mali
je vous rappelle que notre hôte en
mauritanie cette piste est explorée et
ça a permis de freiner la roma deux
mauritaniens à haut niveau d'al-qaïda
qui s'était basée à l'époque dans le
nord du mali est donc au mali j'ai c'est
qu'il ya des voix qui commencent à
s'élever depuis quelques années pour
explorer cette piste à travers une
conférence des chiffres
jugé pour pour se prononcer sur cette
question quelle est la légalité des 2,7
à roulement des enfants dans ces
opérations critiques et artistes est-ce
que c'est donc c'est effectivement c'est
une piste à explorer et sous le toit
n'est pas négligée parce que la guerre
d'avoir lé psychologique quand vous avez
des gamins qui sait que le couloir
vraiment que c'est qu'ils sont en train
de faire c'est que ça va les amener au
paradis et qu'ils auront des femmes et
je sais pas quoi plein de choses il faut
foncer je vous rappelle quand vous voyez
encore le rang de ceux qui constituent
les rangs de ce groupe djihadiste la
plupart ces deux jeunes c'est des
enfants et donc c'est des gens aussi qui
sont en baisse vers d'autres voire
peut-être pour qu'ils réfléchissent à
deux fois avant de s'engager france a
souvent si le mot de la fin
changer les mâles et les mentalités
c'est un travail de longue haleine oui
tout à fait nous sommes dans la guerre
des esprits la gare ni de logique 1 nous
sommes face à une idéologie mortifère le
djihadisme
et effectivement il faut donner de
l'espoir aux jeunes et d'ailleurs des
mots qu'on n'a pas utilisée depuis tout
à l'heure on fait la guerre contre ces
terroristes on la fait bien je pense on
est efficace ça c'est sûr
1 mais on ne gagnera pas cette guerre
s'il n'y a pas un développement
s'il n'y a pas des gouvernants qui
gouverne
s'il n'y a pas de corruption si l'argent
qu'on déverse est utile à tout le monde
et que je crois que quand on n'a plus
grand chose à perdre
on rejoint volonté des djihadistes
puisque effectivement comme l'a dit
monsieur on a semble-t-il un avenir le
problème c'est qu'avec nous cet avenir
reste ce thème des très rapidement car
ces gens là ils seront tués
même s'ils sont jeunes et je crois que
si on veut l'éviter il faut des actions
dans le développement des actions dans
la gouvernance et malheureusement au
mali aujourd'hui il y a quand même un
problème de gouvernance et de
développement
on verra lors de ces deux jours s'il y
aura des
des annonces de gouvernance et d'actions
le rappel sommet du g 500 en ce moment
même à n'djamena la capitale du tchad
merci françois chavance il va permettre
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes respectivement
général de brigade expert en
géostratégie et journalistes maliens